في حدث اليوم نعود الحديث عن فيروس كورونا
والمتحورات الجديده هل يوجد ما يبعث على
القلق سعيد بان يكون معي في الاستوديو
رياض عربي
الدرقوي وهو مختص في الطب المخبري
والمناعه في مستشفى بوجو
اعتقدنا ان الامور انتهت ولكن عندما نرى
تقارير منظمه الصحه العالميه هناك قلق من
الشتاء المقبل
نعم شكرا لاستضافتكم اولا وانا مشاهدين
لقد اعلنت مدام صحه العالميه في شهر ايار
الماضي شهر خمسه الماضي انتهاء الوباء
بشكل عام وكانت يعني بشكل مطمئنه طبعا هذا
لا يعني انها لا تراقب ما يحدث من طفرات
ومن تغيرات فكل فتره يظهر طفره معينه هناك
عده برامج في الدول تستطيع كشف هذه
الطفرات كلها تعتمد على السيكل يعني او
اللي هو الجينات يعني
موجوده في عده الدول وكل ما تظهر طفره
جديده نراقبها فورا ونحاول معرفه مدى
انتشارها وهل هي خطره ام لا وماذا تاثيرها
المتوقع على الوضع الصحي فحاليا ظهرت يعني
مؤخرا ظهرت
تماما اللي هي جايه من الاكس بي بي اللي
هو كله عائله الاوميكرون بطبيعه الحال وهي
كانت تبعث على القلق قليلا لانه هناك سرعه
في الانتشار الرهيبه كانت في فرنسا انا
جئت من في الاطلسه ب 13 تقريبا
في فرنسا اصبح نسبه الانتشار يعني
ذهبت لا يوجد ريس رجعته 30% فكان لو كانت
خطره كانت مقلق هذا الشيء بطبيعه الحال
ومن هنا منظمه الصحه العالميه والدول اصلا
بشكل عام تراقب كل التطورات التي قد تحصل
على الطفرات على عوائل الكوفيد خاصه
بالفتره الاخيره ولاحظت بسبب وجود يعني
بسبب الكشف عن هذا هذا المتحور الجديد
الاخير البيرولاد او او اللي هو العلميا
لاحظت انه هناك اكثر من 100 طفره قد حصلت
وهذا شيء غريب وخاصه منها 50 كان في
بروتين سبايك يعني البروتين الشوكي الذي
عبره يدخل الفيروس الى خلايا التنفسيه هذا
كان مقلقا لانه لم يحدث من قبل يعني حتى
حتى لحظه الظهور عائله اوميكرون يعني كان
عنا الفا ودلتا اذا تذكرون والسلاله
التقليديه بالاصل قبل ذلك
حتى عائله ظهور عائله اوميكرون كان اقصى
طفرات يعني
من تحول الى اخر هنا خمسين طفره يعني او
اكثر بالضبط
ككل واكثر من 30 عفوا تماما في البروتين
سنعود الى اللقاحات من جديد
ممكن ليس بالشكل الذي يعني حصل عندما كان
لا يوجد لقاحات على الاخير
ما يمكن له ان يتاقلم مع هذه المتحورات
اذا نحن اذا ربما دخلنا في مرحله
العوده الى اللقاء الشركات تجهز انفسها
اللقاح بطبيعه الحال طبعا اللقاح اسرع
بكثير
وبالتعديل الان بالنسبه للقاح هو فعال ضده
اوميكرون وكل هذه المتحورات هي من عائله
توميكرون اذا هل هذا اللقاح سيكون مجديا
ام لا نعم اذا ساقول لك بدقه اللقاح
الحاليه الحالي حاليا هو ضد البي اي يعني
الفصيله الاساسيه
المجموعه تحت المجموعه من عائله اوميكرون
الذي
ظهر مؤخرا اللي هو
البيرولاتا
لهذا الاخر
هو اقل تاثرا باللقاح يعني استجابه ولكن
بما انه هلا في لقاح جديد سوف يصل باكتوبر
على هو ما سمعت او كما بالضبط كما تقول
الوزاره الصحه الفرنسيه سوف تشتري من
بعتقد مديرنا
لقاح هو بالاصل يؤثر في الاكس بي بي وتمت
مؤخرا جدا هو هذا لذلك انا متفائل شخصيا
كتير كتير مؤخرا يعني بالاخر ايام الماضيه
تجربه للقاء ليس للقاح للاضداد الموجوده
ضد الاكس بي بي ولكن التي حصلنا عليها
بشكل مكتسب عبر الانتان يعني عندما
الانسان الى الانسان يشكل الضاد هذه
الاضداد
المعدله منها كانت فعاله ضد الاكس بي بي
فاذا جاء اللقاح وهو بالاصل ضد الاكس بي
بيكون مؤثرا جيدا في هذه السلاله الاخيره
اذا الاجراءات الوقائيه تقريبا كل مواطن
تخلى عن كل هذه الاجراءات وهذا هو الاشكال
الكبير لنا الان الطقس الان جميل في فرنسا
وبعد ذلك ستقع عمليه في وضع برد اذا
الكثافه ستكون اكبر اذا الخطر هنا يكمن
هنا له طبعا يكمن الخطر دائما في قدوم فصل
الخريف ومن ثم الشتاء لانه سوف تحصر الناس
في اماكن ضيقه بطبيعه الحال بسبب البرد
معروف هذا في المترو في المكاتب والمقام
تماما في كل الاماكن وبالتالي فخطر
الانشاد اكثر اكثر اذا يجب ان نكون جاهزين
يجب ان يعني ينتبه المراه على كل حقيقه
عندما يكون مريضا عنده حراره او او يعرف
انه ضفدع ويعتقد انه قد يكون الاوميكرون
يعني الكورونا فلا يعرض الاخرين يعني خاصه
من اقربائه ومن الكبار بالعمر ومن
المضعفين المناعه الذين ياخذون ادويه لانه
عندهم مثلا لا سمح الله سرطان او عنده
مثلا مرض مناعي ذاتي ياخذ ادويه لكي يخفف
اثار المرض هؤلاء الناس الذين نعرفهم
لانهم في محيطنا اقربائنا
الزملاء العمل مثلا يجب ان يعني بشعور بنا
المسؤوليه ان نحميهم وبالتالي
نضع الكمامه على الاقل انا كنت في
المناوبه اخر مره وكان في طبيب طبيب عفوا
واضح انها مريضه كانت تضع الكمامه جاءت
للاكل مساء الساعه الثامنه فانا استغربت
صار لي فتره طبعا
يعني هذا التصرف مسؤول يعني شعوريا
ولكن انا اعطيك مثلا ان في فتره الصيف في
الاجازات تسمع كثيرين في وضع
يعني سعال كبير في وضع حراره في حاله يعني
عندما تقول لهم اذهبوا لمحاوله معرفه ان
كانت لكم الكل يضحك لا احد لا احد يقول
الكورونا انتهت وفي العالم العربي
ماذا تقول الى هؤلاء الان في الحقيقه انا
افهم ايضا انه يعني منذ اللحظه التي اتت
فيها عائله اوميكرون اصبحت الاعراض اخف
حقيقه من قبل كان المرض الكورونا
لكن الاعراض موجوده والاهم كما قلنا في
حمايه الناس الذين يعني معرضون بشكل اكثر
فاقول لهم انتبهوا مع ذلك يعني نحن نعلم
ان كل العالم قد اصبح عندها ملل شديد لانه
الموضوع كان هائل ما حصل في الحقيقه في
ثلاثه سنين الماضيه لم يكن المتوقعا
ومفاجئا يعني في ظرف اسبوع يقول لك لا
تخرج خلاص كل الحياه الماضيه انساها لفتره
كذا موضوع يعني اللي صار في اضرار نفسيه
صارت اضرار اقتصاديه صار في كثير من
الامور لذلك يعني المفروض انه
يفهم لماذا الناس يعني الى حد ما لم تعد
تريد كثيرا ان تتبع هذه الاجراءات ولكن
عندما يكون الانسان مريضا حقيقه هنا يعني
الموضوع مختلف على الاقل تعلم انك ممكن
كيف يمكن حتى في فرنسا تم انهاء العمل
بالبروتوكول الصحي في المؤسسات اذا حتى من
هو مصاب يمكن ان يذهب ويعمل المهم ان يحمل
الكمامه صحيح اذا يستطيع ان يعمل حتى
اللحظه التي نعرف انه ليست السلالات يعني
التي
تنتقل من مريض الى اخر هي سلالات خطيره
يعني اذا رجعنا لموضوع دلتا والفا وهذول
من الممكن ان تتغير هذه القواعد فورا يعني
لذلك هو ومن هنا المراقبه الشديده دائما
لكل سلاله جديده تطرا يعني لكي نعرف انه
حصل تسرع في اتخاذ الاجراءات برفع كل
الاجراءات الوقائيه ام لا برايك
لا اعتقد انه حصل تسرع بالنتيجه لانه حصلت
عده اغلاقات متكرره في عده دول في كثير من
الدول حتى الصين التي كانت تتبع السياسه
الاقصى على الاقل على الاكثر يعني على
اقصى سياسه في العالم كانت تقريبا حتى هي
اضطرت يعني تحت ضغط معين ان تترك هذه من
المستحيل المتابعه بنفس الطريقه لابد كان
من اللجوء الى طريقه يعني افضل على الاقل
حمايه كما قلت الناس الذي اعمارهم فوق
الخمسين سنه المسنين مثلا
اعتبارا من 50 عين الاحصائيات انا بحكي
فقط على الاحصائيات ما في مشكله كبيره بس
دائما الناس اللي عندهم الامراض المزمنه
الامراض نقص المناعه اللي عندهم ادويه
معينه تؤدي لنقص مناعتهم ايضا او المسنين
بشكل عام لانه بالاصل كانوا من قبل
الكوفيد اصلا في كان 10,000 او 12 الف
حاله بين عشره الى 12 الف حاله في فرنسا
يموتون من فلونزا العاديه من قريب العادي
معروفه الاحصائيات تعزى الى هذا
على كل من الافضل دائما ان نمنع مرض من
مثلا نضع كمامه في لحظه ما وخلاص وفيما
بعد لا نضعها في الشارع لا نضعها في
الهواء الطلق لا نضعها هل هو فيروس مطمن
مطمئن سوف نرى يعني هو كتير بكير انه نقدر
نعرف يعني
مبكر انه نعرف على الخوف ولكن لا يوجد لا
يوجد لا في في لماذا ايضا انا متفائل لانه
عائلته الميكرون قد اصابت كثير من الناس
فكثير من الناس عندها اصلا هذه مناعه الى
حد ما لم تمنع انتشار المرض ولكن تمنع
الاقل الاصابه الشديده بالمرض يعني خاصه
عند الناس العاديين الوضع الطبيعي الناس
اللي قلنا بوضعهم خاص هدول بوضع خاص بس
الناس الطبيعيين لن يحدث لهم شيء على
الاغلب الامور بخير يعني ليس كما جاء
عندما جاء الكوفيد لم يكن احد يعني عنده
اي اضداد ضده فورا وكان للفتره اللازمه
لكي ان يعني لكي تتشكل هذه المناعه
المجموعيه التي تخفف من الانتشار بشكل عام
كانت
ضروريه لكي السنه سنتين يعني عمل علميا
والحل الان هو لقاح لا يمكن ان نفكر في
ادويه مثلا
الحقيقه كل الادويه التي ظهرت خاصه يعني
تعطى خاصه بشكل خاص على الضاد وحيده في
المشفى يعني من الممكن ان ناخذ بعض
الادويه التي يعني قيل انه هذا يخفف من
تواجد الفيروس في الانف او الاخر يخفف
الاعراض الفيتامين دال لا ليست هناك يعني
مو واضح يعني
ان نؤكدها بشكل كبير لان من حصل على يعني
من تعرض للعدوى بشكل كبير مريض يعني
بالنتيجه وهناك كثير لم يكونوا ياخذون اي
دواء ولم يحصل لهم شيئا يعني وهناك قليل
كانوا ياخذون بيجوز ادويه وحصل لهم
فالموضوع في كثير عوامل تلعب دور كثير
عوامل هو فيروس ملعون الشكر العربي دار
قوي شكرا جزيلا لك فترتكم سي متواصله على
فرانس 24 ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]